welcome to the first verse that's a joke
from RuPaul's Drag Race oh wow this is
an intense start I know I'm going back
now hi guys my name is grace Helbig if
you did not know now you know your life
is different now
somehow hopefully for the good not
always I have that effect I don't know
my tumblr the other day and I asked you
guys what kind of things you wanted to
see a lot of you said different things
all surrounding RuPaul's Drag Race which
is ideal
I'm binge watch the most recent season
of RuPaul's Drag Race over the weekend
ah damn it I love it so much if you
don't know what the show is it's a drag
queen competition and it is it's so much
more than that and that might sound
cheesy or cliche but it really is drag
queens are to me some of the most
impressive artists in this world
it sounds very dramatic and they're
amazing their artistry of makeup and
hair and clothing is absolutely so out
of my league which is perfect because
today I'm going to attempt to do a drag
queen makeup look on my face I've been
binge-watching a drag queen named Miss
fame on YouTube and I stumbled upon four
natural blonde makeup tutorial the word
natural and like drag queen makeup
tutorial being in the same universe as
each other
drag queens not only are they amazing
artists they're amazing comedians I
can't
I like drag queens so much that it makes
my body turn into this thing so I
watched this tutorial a couple times and
now I'm going to try to recreate it on
my face and I'm around I'm gonna
actually try that's also my dirty talk
I'm actually very very nervous because
there's something about letting a drag
queen down that makes me fill up with
anxiety this is a whole new set of daddy
issues she starts out with her eyes he
does this light brown thing to
accentuate this part of her eyes oh my
god I'm so nervous I feel like I'm
taking the SATs right now on my face Oh
with the prime prime the eyes I'm gonna
spray this
that's a sound of freshness oh that did
probably nothing good thing I spent $30
on it I'm gonna put this all over the
eyes I also recently did my own acrylic
nails I want to say because I am very
light DIY savvy but no mostly just
because I don't like human interaction
so instead of going to a nail salon I
struggled through trying to do it myself
unhealthy hormones and now we have to do
okay she makes it look so easy
Jesus Christ you ever wonder what I
sound like in a threesome also miss fame
you are so handsome beautiful as a woman
handsome as a man mmm
stop I mean no continue it's very
inspiring he's using a light brown
pencil do I have that okay you tried
this we're gonna give the illusion of a
bigger lid I'm gonna draw a light brown
it's like sweeping thing wow that's a
thing I don't just ran in from outside
which means she just took a [ __ ] so
we're both expressing our art right now
now I need to let soft brown soft brown
I need a soft Browns and I say every
morning through the toilet a lot of
blending that happens oh boy I don't
think I'm getting this faith we're
trying miss fame did you guys watch this
season of drag race I haven't seen in
the finale I don't know who wins and I
don't know who I want to win I really
like teaching but I also I really like
him gee they were just like cheese that
Bob though
oh oh okay several neutral shades to
define this line oh my god oh boy I
think this is a thing something's
happening then look yes more blending
what oh my god she's using infinitely
tinier and tinier brushes alright we're
doing other shades smearing them kind of
on the doubt is real oh that's a good
drag name miss Doubtfire just someone
that's very insecure
that could work for me kind of comes
down the nose and feel very medium about
this
okay now it was white and white going on
okay I got some white here glitter of my
choice
god I'm so indecisive let's put some
white on I ate a flat brush okay oh boy
that was too much okay look we got some
white oh I'm definitely the very very JV
version of miss fame right now probably
didn't even make it on the team I think
I'm probably keeping score I'm like an
intern for the score keepers right now
okay okay so now we're gonna go up into
the here area above now oh wow white
shadow over top of this creamy [ __ ] so
now I need a glitter do I have a glitter
so I just have these like kind of
shimmery eyeshadows are good are so
pretty I had a gold glitter for a really
long time then I think I threw it away
because I had never used it great story
all right let's try one of these things
let's see what happens very technically
just putting some gold got some gold
glitter
now she's lining her eyes with a black
eyeliner mm any eyeliner on this is
always fun to do on camera
hahaha that's right goose talk amongst
yourselves here's the topic what else
are drag queens better than you
everything I am angry okay I got black
on that I really okay okay uh on I got
more than the other let's do this and
just touch the eyeliner like we know
what we're doing I'm gonna tension it
with this brush see what makes us look
like miss fame I wind it out a little
bit thing alright that looks like a
thing sure what else you got miss fame
so now we get into our face we're gonna
beat this face I think that's what they
say
I don't know I'm such a nerd drag race
fan I want to be so cool to them but I'm
just so not okay so miss fame just puts
a whole thing of foundation on first
let's do whatever miss fame does except
maybe in the bedroom I don't know if
this is my skin tone we're gonna just go
for it
alright wow I'm so good at this never
take a beauty blender and blend this in
you're so pretty
cheers more Brown in this area
I'm gonna add some more Brown okay so we
need a skin enhancer can we just get a
transplant I'm gonna use this NARS
Chantilly can we do a little bit on my
nose here and here but Hays is so shiny
and pretty I'm gonna add some shiny
stuff shimmering skin perfecter I'm
gonna add this OH now we blended then
he's using his ring finger oh oh that's
a lot product oh no it's not it's great
you're doing a great job so yeah love
yourself so you can love everybody else
it seems fine you're fine and now we get
into the contour this is where things
really happen here we go oh man this
thing is going for it I have a darker
foundation but then I also have some
contouring stuff too
let's try this first so I tried
contouring before you wouldn't know that
by this the wow that looks really great
oh no bun this is weird - I want to see
your face on my face miss fame okay so
we want to do a good nose contour we
need let's get let's go my god I'm now
I'm so excited and overwhelmed all the
same time it's your shoe not crying oh
my god oh my god never blend missing oh
my god oh my god I don't think I have
enough highlighter more is more that's
what they always say oh my god it's
doing something on my face oh I'm
getting very excited now okay oh my god
now we need to set under here with
powder good bake or something god I'm
such a nerd okay oh and she puts it down
there - what watch you put the powder
down here on their cheeks oh my god I
think I've said oh my god a lot this is
quite a religious experience
so now we brush so now I need to
continue to scroll the face with powder
you need a different brush a better
brush for sculpting I'm sculpting oh my
god look I look like I know what I'm
doing Nina shadow brush tiny the
continued if I my nose continue to find
your nose continue to define the
oh boy I really defined it but that
looks not bad good we're defining the
nose I think I found my nose oh I have
found my nose Nichole softer all right
you guys have all said that I look like
Michael Jackson for months and months on
different videos on this YouTube channel
so ask and you shall receive pink blush
to the cheeks we need pink blush on the
cheeks everyone calm down
oh ho there's some pink blush on those
cheeks yeah I do look like Michael
Jackson got a damn now what a highlight
powder oh no I have this shimmering skin
thing oh we got it open too much oh oh
there we got some shimmer going Oh
eyebrows cut damn it okay mr. M uses her
natural eyebrows usually people move
down their eyebrows and put new eyebrows
on but I'm gonna use my natural eyebrows
we're going for a very natural subtle
look here can't not look at my nose I'm
gonna try to redefine my not dry brows
let's see we can do let me know if you
want me to try in the future a look
where I glue down my eyebrows and put on
new eyebrows I can't stop looking at my
nose I'm freaked out and also like
really sexually attracted to myself
right now
whoa okay
I'm actually really impressive myself oh
and if you stood up for all of you that
I've said in the past that I go too
heavy on my eyebrows not today
[ __ ] now I'll be really impressed if
I can get these eyebrows to match each
other this is very stressful
this must be what defusing bomb is like
is a helicopter coming to take me away
to the drag FBI because I'm too good at
this miss fame obviously does a much
more delicate and beautiful job in your
tutorial but hey this is what I ended up
with now we're gonna seal them with some
Berle Joe what's next miss fame white
concealer underneath of there
I can't sing stop looking at my nose
okay we need to curl our eyelashes very
exciting now we put a little coat of
mascara on top and bottom top and bottom
top of us at the indecisive homosexual
this year's is a white eyeliner on her
lower waterline
have a white eyeliner I have a silver
okay oh wait she put a [ __ ] already
she put eyelashes on oh this is the
worst part I got these things this is
gonna be real bad if you've ever watched
a candy Johnson video she puts on
eyelashes like she's scratching an itch
like it's the most simple thing like a
straight girl trying to do drag makeup
who's got to be tacky you can do it just
have confidence to blink out the blue
guy stuff like that you know why not
let's do the other one can't imagine me
giving first no it didn't they would the
other oh my god oh my god okay okay it
gets better
let's get some eyeliner on to cover up
this glue oh my god we sort of did it
okay now it's just lips and she does a
dark dark lip overdrawn classically I
got some dark colors we're gonna do a
dark lip like Miss fern outline it first
okay okay who ever got a good nose for
their actual lip color on top oh my god
okay oh my god
so oh my god I got it I'm gonna do my
hair really quickly and then we'll come
back and look at the full look all
together Tom oh my gosh I mean I can't
stop looking at myself here's my full
transformation I don't completely look
like Miss fame and they definitely don't
look like grace Helbig anymore you know
what they say sometimes when you try you
just might surprise yourself and yeah
I'm surprised let me know what you guys
think leave a comment down below and
what I mean
have I made myself speechless give this
video thumbs up if you enjoyed it I want
me to do other tutorials in the future
was this even a tutorial to know let me
know what you think my drag queen
alter-ego should be because that is
absolutely essential don't forget to
subscribe because this is this videos
like this are important and let me know
if you guys have been watching drag race
and your favorite part of it my favorite
part of it is probably the part about
everything about it yeah that's a good
part thanks for watching I'll see you
guys uh you know I'm here but am i I
don't know I was younger I wanted Barbie
dolls and my dad didn't want me to have
them because he didn't think that
Barbies were a good influence for young
girls so the only one you could
rationalize actually buying for me was
the Native American bar because he
thought it was somewhat educational or
historical and look where I am now this
is kind of my GG gorgeous cosplay oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god why
are you am i cutting self or just
putting glue on this is the easy part
you're right thanks for talking me down
uh I've actually developed an alter-ego